there are hundreds of billions of alien
worlds in the Milky Way
galaxy and scientists have already
discovered and confirmed over 5,000 of
them they call these worlds exoplanets
some of them are really small like
Kepler 37b this tiny planet is even
smaller than Mercury the smallest planet
in our solar system Kepler 37 is just
slightly larger than our own Moon it
could easily replace our Cosmic
companion in the night sky only it's
pretty far from us this tiny space rock
is located 208 light years from Earth
where it orbits a star that's a bit
smaller and cooler than our sun small
rocky worlds like Kepler 37b are a
pretty rare find because they're so tiny
they're more difficult to spot but
scientists have still managed to confirm
about 200 of these worlds most of them
are many many times closer to their
Stars than our planet is to the Sun and
Kepler 62c is no exception this Mars
sized exoplanet orbits its star roughly
four times closer than Mercury orbits
our sun it only takes a little over 12
Earth days to make a full orbit Kepler
62c must be scorching hot and extremely
volcanic definitely not the kind of
place you'd want to
visit and neither is this exoplanet Ki
55b scientists think this planet used to
be the size of Jupiter but then its Sun
exploded into a red giant and swallowed
the planet whole h no surprise there koi
55b is incredibly close to its star so
close that it takes this hellish World
less than 5 hours to make one orbit and
koi 55b is evaporating so much that it
will soon disappear from its planetary
system it's not alone many of these
planets have their atmospheres torn Away
by their host Stars some 41 light years
from Earth there's a super Earth that
used to be a mini
Neptune GJ 113 2 B might have had a
thick hydrogen atmosphere in the past
but its young hot star stripped it away
leaving only a rocky core
behind when its star Stripped Away its
original atmosphere some of the gases
were absorbed into the planet's mantle
and now through this planet's volcanism
they're released back GJ 1132 B could
have become a potentially habitable
world but it's 26 times closer to its
star than Mercury is to the sun no
chances for life on this super
Earth but life might be possible on
these slightly larger super Earths
scientists have found many of these
worlds orbiting In Their sunlike Stars
habitable zones and that's good news now
we'd have to go and explore more of
these planets up close to find out what
their atmospheres are like this one
seems intriguing Kepler
452b is 1.6 time the size of Earth and
it's about 6 billion years old Earth is
a youngster compared to this world our
planet is only 4 and 1/2 billion years
old okay now I know this is your
favorite exoplanet Kepler
22b and I like it too this super Earth
might be covered in a super ocean it
sits comfortably in it it stars
habitable zone and has a huge potential
for Life the only problem is that it's
big Kepler 22b is 2.4 times larger than
Earth and about nine times more massive
if Kepler 22b was the size of Earth it
would have an average surface
temperature of about 16° C but because
it's a lot bigger than Earth it could be
a rocky planet a water world or even a
gaseous Planet like Neptune
and speaking of gaseous planets at this
size exoplanets stop being super Earths
and become gas giants more than half of
all exoplanets we've discovered are
either neptun like ice Giants or gas
giants like
Jupiter many of them orbit a little too
close to their host stars and they pay a
high price for that proximity for one
they're incredibly hot and sometimes
their host star rips their atmosphere
away H kind of like what GJ 1132 B went
through but among them there are some
cold planets too o this is Kepler 16b
it's not quite as large as Jupiter but
the cool thing about it is that it
orbits not one but two stars only you
wouldn't be able to see those stars
because you wouldn't be able to stand on
its surface you see Kepler 16b is a s P
sized gas giant it might have some rocky
elements inside it but its two host
stars are much cooler than our sun
making Kepler 16b a frigid lifeless
World okay now on to the worlds that are
bigger than Jupiter this delicious
exoplanet has the density of a
marshmallow toi 3757 B is slightly
larger than Jupiter but it's not nearly
as massive but there are always bigger
and batter planets out there like Kepler
7B this one is interesting Kepler 7B is
larger than Jupiter but it has half of
Jupiter's mass this means the planet is
like a super light Cloud a scorching hot
Superlight Cloud Kepler 7B is a hot
Jupiter planet it's 12 times hotter than
the king of the solar system still
Kepler 7B is not the hottest or the
weirdest of the
exoplanets some of these gas giants are
so unimaginably hot that they tear
molecules apart yeah and some planets
are just doomed 1,400 light years away
from Earth a star slightly bigger and
hotter than our sun is devouring its
Planet this planet is called wasp 12b
it's almost double the size of Jupiter
but it's not going to last very long as
far as planetary lives go wasp 12b is so
close to its star that it takes just
over one Earth day to complete its orbit
its own star is actually eating the
planet's atmosphere making it stretch
into the shape of this egg 10 million
years from now wasp 12b will be gone and
some exoplanets are unimaginably huge
the biggest one of them is almost seven
times larger than Jupiter
hd1000 546b isn't just seven times
larger than Jupiter it's also 750 times
more massive HD orbits its star 10 times
further away than Jupiter orbits the sun
that's pretty far and it makes
scientists wonder how this gigantic
exoplanet formed so far away from its
star there's no doubt that some
exoplanets out there look promising for
finding life
we've found quite a lot of them orbiting
in the habitable zone of Their
Stars every year our planet makes one
full trip around the Sun and while that
means we're already moving at break neck
speeds we're about to ramp that speed up
like way up let's turn the earth into a
planet-sized spaceship and crank it up
to light
speed why would this make earth
extremely
heavy what would happen to Earth if it
started orbiting so
fast and what would it be like to
experience all this from down on the
ground this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth orbited the
Sun at the speed of
light okay nothing travels fast faster
than light so brace yourself because
light moves through space at a
blistering
300,000 km/
second that means from the moment a
particle of light leaves the sun hurling
directly toward you on Earth it takes
just 8 minutes before it hits you in the
face or gently caresses your
face yeah it only takes light 8 minutes
to travel
150 million km and light reflecting off
the moon only needs 1 second to reach
your eyes now when it comes to an object
cranking up to the speed of light things
aren't just as simple as picking up the
pace let's take our planet as it gets
closer to the speed of light its mass
increases until it becomes
infinite and to move an infinite massive
object you're going to need an infinite
amount of energy and that's just
impossible until
now Earth already orbits the Sun at 30
km/s and while that's not slow at all
compare it to the speed of light and
that's not even a drop in the bucket if
you want to be more precise Earth orbits
this big scorching ball at only
0.01% of the speed of light so we've got
a lot of ground to cover here but don't
get ahead of yourself because even if we
just increased Earth's orbital velocity
to 42 km/ second we'd be in serious
danger that's because at this speed
Earth would achieve its orbital escape
velocity that means it would be
traveling fast enough to escape the the
sun's gravitational pull we'd just be
traveling out into space another cold
Rogue planet with no star system to call
home of course we'd cross the solar
system before being ejected out of it
for good after about 3 years of moving
at this speed Earth would reach Neptune
at that point we'd have already passed
all the other planets in the outer solar
system if we got really unlucky Earth
might might crash into the big ball of
gas Jupiter along the way now for a
moment that would be a pretty view as we
approached but what a shame it wouldn't
last long enough for you to enjoy
because Earth colliding with Jupiter
would have some lethal side
effects but we wouldn't let your Epic
Journey end so abruptly in this scenario
Earth would keep hurdling through the
solar system and beyond we'd keep
speeding further further and further out
of our planetary Hometown and into the
big
unknown and without the sun's heat well
Earth would slowly but surely become a
cold and lifeless
Rock okay well that didn't go as planned
at all so how about we start
over let's break the laws of physics and
keep our planet in the sun's orbit as it
reaches light speed what would that be
like well to accelerate the entire
planet to such an incredible speed we
need a lot of energy how much well more
than you could
imagine even if you wanted to accelerate
yourself to only about 90% of the speed
of light well you'd need as much energy
as the entire world consumes in 5 days
so where in the universe would we manage
to get enough energy to speed the whole
planet up well your best bet would be to
follow the lead of a very rare but
extremely fast kind of star a hyper
velocity star these are stars that can
reach speeds of up to 33% of the speed
of light there may be as few as 1,000 of
these kinds of stars in our entire
galaxy all because they need a unique
chain of events to unfold first hyper
velocity Stars reach their hypers speeds
by orbiting a black hole that's
colliding with another black hole these
two black holes begin a kind of dance
with each other spinning faster and
faster until eventually they let go and
that gravitational disruption leads to
the Stars being ejected Across the
Universe at these insane
speeds all right so it's simple in order
for us to reach the speed of light we
just need to swing around a black hole
or two what's the worst that could
happen
there now experiencing light speed on
Earth wouldn't be exactly like what you
see in the movies when the Millennium
Falcon or the USS Enterprise engaged
thrusters for starters you wouldn't see
any more stars in the night sky that's
because you'd be experiencing what's
known as the Doppler effect in
scientific terms all the light traveling
toward Earth would now have a higher
frequency moving from the visible
spectrum into the X-ray range to put it
simply the light from the Stars would
become invisible to you because the
human ey can't see
X-rays and it could mean invisible
danger for for you x-rays can cause many
health problems and increase your risk
of cancer while today's atmosphere is
thick enough to prevent most of this
radiation from Stars reaching us
traveling at the speed of light might
put our atmosphere to the test yeah we
could lose our protective air Shield
which also means on this Earth that you
wouldn't be able to
breathe but even if our atmospheres
somehow stayed in place traveling at
light speed would quickly damage it even
something as small as a hydrogen
molecule would become an incredible
Hazard slamming into our atmosphere at
such high velocities it could cook it
into
Oblivion and I'm not sure you'd enjoy
being on Earth if it suddenly lost its
atmosphere on our hypothetical Journey
we've already already tested out living
on a flat
Earth a cubicle Earth even a hollow
Earth so what do you say we try to
survive on an Earth with a giant hole in
the
middle would a planet like this even
have a chance of being
habitable would it still have the
moon how would gravity work and what
would the view be like on an earth like
this this this is what if and here's
what would happen if the Earth was
shaped like a
dut hey planetar speaking Size Matters
and so does
shape this is what mathematicians would
call a toroidal world or a Taurus planet
to me it's an earth shaped like a sweet
fried ring-shaped
pastry whatever you call call this Earth
theoretically it's not
impossible planets don't naturally form
in the shape of a donut but the laws of
physics do allow for such worlds to
exist it just wouldn't be Earth as you
know
it okay I'm just messing with you here
it wouldn't kill anyone to evolve on a
donut-shaped earth unless it had a shape
more like a hula hoop having a center
that's so much larger than the
physically solid portion of Earth would
result in some very unstable
conditions see what I mean
disastrous so let's focus on a planet
that looks like a traditional doughnut
and closely mimics our own
Earth this doughnut-shaped Earth would
have a similar position relative to the
sun and the same actual tilt it would
even have a similar escape velocity 11.4
km/s from most of the planet at the
donuts Equator the escape Velocity would
go down to just 6 and 1/2
km/s so if you were going to send
Rockets into space that would be the
best place to break free of the
gravitational clutches of a donut-shaped
earth speaking of gravity depending
where you were on a Taurus Earth you'd
weigh up to three times less than you
usually
do if our round earth has a surface
gravity of 1 G
the surface gravity of a donut Earth
along the poles would be 0.65 G and at
the Equator the gravity would go down to
just 0.3 G it would be like walking on
the surface of
Mars even though the donut shaped
Earth's gravity would be lower than what
you're used
to it would still be constantly trying
to collapse the planet in on
itself to fight the urge to become a
sphere-shaped earth a donut Earth would
have to spin much faster than our round
earth
does that way centrifugal forces would
kick in and keep the doughnut hole
intact but because of this quick
rotation a day on Earth would only last
2 hours and 50
minutes or if you prefer to stick to a
traditional 24-hour day you'd be dealing
with at least eight sunrises and sunsets
every
day you'd have to adapt to Working Day
and Night and sleeping through hours of
daylight but it would be much worse than
that for the animals that are synced to
the patterns of the moon in the sun to
breed migrate and
Hunt oh and by the way what would happen
to the
Moon well the good news is we'd still
have it most likely it would be pulled
towards the middle of the hole and bob
up and down in the middle of the
planet or it could be affected by the
gravity of the dut's outer edges and
create a figure8 orbit around the
Earth the bad news is either of these
orbits would affect the tides on Earth
and wreak a little
Havoc oceans could have such unstable
water levels that having coastal cities
might not be a
thing the overall climate on a donut
Earth would be similar to what we
currently have on our round earth it
would be colder in the polar regions and
warmer at the equator
but the weather would be a little more
extreme and could even make some parts
of the planet inhospitable due to storms
and
hurricanes it's hard to predict where
the countries would be located on a
Taurus Planet but as far as topography
goes most likely the doughnut hole would
be lined with mountains and they could
be substantially larger than anything we
have on Earth right
now if you wanted to live on the inner
edge of a donut-shaped earth Earth you'd
be enjoying this
view
ah unlike in some what if scenarios life
wouldn't come to an end in this
one humans of a donut Earth might never
cross the ocean they'd evolve separately
on different continents but at least
there would be no mass extinction and no
areas of the planet would become too
extreme for us to
survive donut earthers might or might
not have the tools and Tech we have
today they might not even stumble onto
the concept of a donut in the first
place or they could be making videos
like what if the Earth was shaped like a
ball and maybe because of this dut shape
some disasters in Earth's history would
never have
[Music]
happened
right now wherever you are you are
spinning with our planet at a speed of
hundreds of meters per second but what
if our planet started hitting the brakes
until our world didn't spin at
all why would it be harder for you to
move
around why would some parts of the world
actually benefit from
this and why could this Slowdown prent
provide you with the trip of a
lifetime this is what if and here's what
would happen if Earth gradually came to
a
standstill Earth's rotation on its axis
is the reason why you experience day and
night over the 24 hours that it takes to
do a full spin except it doesn't rotate
evenly everywhere at the Equator this
speed is over 460 m/ second second but
the closer you get to the poles the
slower our planet turns whether it's
north or south the rotational speed is
almost
zero millions of years ago it only took
Earth 22 hours to spin on its axis and
with every passing Century our days
become 2 milliseconds longer now if that
deceleration intensified and the planet
went to a complete standstill within a
year you might have to get used to a
daily dose of
catastrophe the first sign that the
great slowdown is underway would be
radical changes in the weather this is
because as the Earth rotates it gives
rise to the coroli effect air in the
northern hemisphere is deflected to the
right while in the southern hemisphere
it's deflected to the left
this also means that hot air veers away
from the poles but as the planet slowed
down the Warm Winds from the equator
would slowly start to make their way to
the top and bottom of the globe and in
the meantime cool air from the poles
would also sink back down to the equator
these changes in Wind patterns would
have disastrous consequences they would
drive rainfall and raise temp
temperatures around the world your
summer Cottage in the forest could
become surrounded by a sprawling desert
and where a frozen tundra once stood
farmable land could emerge these changes
would disrupt ecosystems around the
world unable to adapt plants and animals
would
die on the other hand the days of
hurricanes would be numbered Corola
forces create hurricanes and without
them
they just wouldn't
form and the changes to the world around
you wouldn't end there our planet would
begin to ease up on the spinning but by
no means would the ground stay put you
see Earth is like an onion it's made up
of layers the crust the mantle and the
core and as the onion we call home
slowed down these layers might not do so
in un
this would result in intense friction
between them which equals Tremors and
lava The year-long Slowdown would be a
deluge of earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions Sweden Saudi Arabia and other
regions not accustomed to these natural
disasters would get their
taste if you made it to the other side
of this shaky and heated period well
you'd be rewarded with a planet where
seismic activity would be a thing of the
past now the ocean is where you'd
witness the most astounding changes to
our shared home you see those globes at
school tricked you Earth is not a
perfect sphere it bulges at the
Equator this is a result of the
centrifugal force caused by you guessed
it the planet's
rotation as it turns Earth gets squished
and its equatorial diameter becomes 43
km longer than the polar
radius as Earth slowed down its middle
bump would
shrink the oceans would start to Flow
Away from the equator and Rush toward
the poles if you lived near the beach
you'd noticed it's Coastline receding a
clear sign that something is wrong and
hope your house by the water isn't in
the northern region of our planet Canada
the United States and Greenland could be
swallowed by the big blue sea as would
the northern regions of Siberia Asia and
Europe sorry about
that now things would look much brighter
in the South as the oceans pulled to the
poles new land would be extending out
Africa would now merge with
Madagascar a Australia and New Guinea
and eventually Indonesia would make the
shift by the time the year is over and
Earth arrives at a standstill the
equatorial region would be completely
drained leaving behind a giant mega
continent a chunk of real estate so
massive that it would Circle the entire
world splitting the ocean in two we'll
call it the ring no not that ring this
one is literally more
groundbreaking this gargantuan land mass
would allow you to walk the entire strip
of the Equator on foot travel companies
would capitalize on the mega continent
to offer you packages to Trek the
circumference of our planet on foot
forget Everest manage this Monumental
feat and you could brag to your friends
about conquering the ring it's cool
naturally you wouldn't be the only went
up for the journey the slower the Earth
spun the longer our days and nights
would become and once the rotation stops
completely one day on Earth would last 6
months during halfe Cycles the planet
would see extreme temperature
fluctuations from a freezing minus 55° C
to a scorching plus 55°
C not to mention a complete breakdown of
our biological circadian rhythms 6
months of darkness could lead to a spike
in skeletal deformities and dental
issues thanks to a global shortage of
natural vitamin D you could also expect
an influx of Seasonal effective disorder
with symptoms such as loss of energy
oversleeping and feelings of
hopelessness so traveling the ring would
be as much about remaining within a
weather sweet spot as it would be about
going on an
adventure not that gravity would be on
your side for it as Earth slows down
you'd notice you have a harder time
moving
around you wouldn't look heavier but
your bathroom scale would say
otherwise that's because a spinning
Earth produces an outward centrifugal
force which cancels a portion of its
gravity no Ro rotation means you get to
experience the full gravitational pull
and with that comes the sensation of
feeling like you've packed on a few
extra
kilos get off the scale eventually
things would get worse our planet's
magnetic field partially produced by its
rotation would disappear and expose you
to harmful solar
radiation human civilization would be
left dealing with frequent vital
servicing outages and irreparable damage
to power grids internet connections and
navigation
systems but if Earth suddenly stopped
spinning
overnight a defective smartphone would
be the least of your
[Music]
worries it's a small world after all
because today we're shrinking Earth to
the size of
Pluto but if our planet was this tiny
how would it alter the
atmosphere why would Earth get
hter and how would gravity affect our
water
supply this is what if and here's what
would happen if Earth was the size of
Pluto Pluto sits on the Solar System's
Edge just beyond Neptune's orbit it was
once considered a planet but then in
2006 scientists demoted this Celestial
body to a dwarf planet all because Pluto
isn't big enough to gravitationally
dominate in its own orbit after all this
dwarf planet is only 2/3 the diameter of
our moon so if Earth was as Tiny as
Pluto how would 8 billion people fit on
it say goodbye to your personal Elbow
Room we would have to fit everyone into
an area slightly bigger than Russia 71%
of which would be covered with
oceans but the good news is this
shrunken Earth would still have room for
everyone just barely you and every
person on the planet would have about
one and a half tennis courts to
yourselves the problem is that doesn't
take into account the space we need for
hospitals airports and roads once we
build those things would start getting
cramped add to that all the
uninhabitable areas like deserts and
mountains and you won't have enough room
to comfortably fit
everyone but if you're looking for a
quick Escape it would be easy for you to
make a break for it one jump could
catapult you almost 7.6 m into the air
and that leap would last for almost 10
seconds giving you a spectacular view of
the Horizon you could also run faster
since there would be less friction but
watch out for slick surfaces they could
send you flying long distances because
there wouldn't be enough gravity to keep
you in place and refrain from
overexerting yourself with all this
running on this dwarf planet the air
pressure would also will be
small so no matter where you're at it
would feel like standing on a
Mountaintop 5,000 m High yeah with less
oxygen to breathe you would be
constantly gasping for air if you're
lucky this high altitude sickness will
leave you lightheaded but if you're
unlucky it could kill
you but even that wouldn't be the worst
case scenario if the Milky way always
had a mini Earth technically the lack of
gravity would make earth
uninhabitable a study out of Harvard
from 2019 found that a planet needs a
mass of at least
2.7% of the earth to keep water on the
surface if Earth had formed to be the
size of Pluto 4 and 1/2 billion years
ago it would never have its Mighty
oceans now how would this affect the
moon well Pluto's largest moon Kon
doesn't orbit the dwarf planet instead
the two bodies are tidy locked with the
same sides always facing each other our
dwarf Earth would be forever facing the
moon in the same position locked in
place by a Common Center of mass caused
by our competing gravitational pulse but
all of this would be the least of our
our problems if Earth was this small its
inner core would be much cooler now that
might sound good at first earthquakes
would stop because there wouldn't be
shifting tectonic plates anymore
volcanoes would become harmless
mountains but unfortunately Earth
wouldn't have a protective magnetic
field without the hot molten core with
this gone the radiation from the Sun
would fry our
planet now what if Earth wasn't formed
to be the size of Pluto What If instead
it suddenly shrunk well then our planet
would keep its mass but that would make
the surface gravity 30 times stronger
than what it is now with intense
training the human body can survive on a
planet with four times the Earth's
gravity but a planet it with 10 times
the gravity of Earth that would break
your bones if you weighed 75 Kg before
now you would weigh around
2300 kg every move you make would take
Serious muscle power and you may not
have it in you no matter how hard you
try an instantaneous dwarf Earth would
cause Mass devastation it could destroy
everything we love about this planet and
leave Humanity hanging on for dear
life trees are falling ecosystems are
collapsing and our infrastructure is
crumbling crops are failing and water is
scarce Earth is becoming a dead planet
on the plus side there's never been a
better time to buy property
but who can think about real estate when
they can't leave their own home let
alone get out of bed let alone
breathe this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth was as big as
the
sun everyone knows the sun is big I mean
look at it and that's just how big it
looks from about 150 million km away
just imagine what it would look like if
you were standing next to
it never mind the sun accounts for 98%
of the mass of our entire solar system
and compared to the densest Planet which
is our very own planet Earth the Sun is
more than a million times more massive
in fact it would take roughly
1,300,000 Planet Earths to fill the
entire Sun but what if it only took
one Earth Earth would be a very
different place if it were the same size
as the sun just imagine our whole
planet's topography being stretched out
continents would expand providing much
needed relief in places where
overpopulation inhibits the quality of
life and owning a nice plot of land
might actually be more affordable than
it is on today's planet Earth but now
we'd also have to consider that every
body of water on our planet would have
more area to cover this means that Lakes
rivers and even the oceans would be
shallower making them more susceptible
to evaporation and potentially drying
out marine life would undoubtedly suffer
since shallower water would gain more
heat from the Sun jeopardizing sea
creatures that need colder water to
survive with other smaller water sources
beginning to dry up Wildlife on land
might have to relocate or travel much
farther for fresh water which would also
put them at risk us hum humans would be
in an equally precarious position Not
only would we probably start fighting
over the limited fresh water that's
available our food crop yields would
also start shrinking food crops need a
certain amount of soil to grow in and to
absorb the nutrients they need if our
world was as big as the sun then like
the water our soil would have to be
spread out to cover a much larger space
less soil would mean less food while the
demand for food would stay the same
there's also another issue that we
haven't considered which when we Factor
it in makes life on Earth pretty much
impossible Earth being the same size as
the sun is hard enough to imagine but
when you consider a sun-sized earth
having the same mass as the sun it
doesn't only jeopardize our survival it
disrupts our entire solar system think
about it with the Earth as big as the
sun you'd pretty much lose the moon
either way but if a planet has more mass
it will also have a stronger
gravitational pull in this case gravity
on Earth would be 28 times as strong as
it is now we'll get to how this affects
you in a moment but first let's look at
the bigger picture the reason why our
solar system moves the way it does now
is because the Sun's mass is so great
its gravitational pull forces other
planets into its orbit the sun currently
has 98% of the mass in our entire solar
system but now the Sun and the Earth
would each have 49% of the mass in our
solar system would this result in some
sort of binary system in which the Sun
and the Earth orbited each other how
would this new rivalry affect the orbits
of the other planets in our solar system
and would a significantly higher
gravitational pull mean that Earth would
get hit by a a lot more
asteroids well there'd be a lot more to
worry about than just
asteroids our satellites would also
probably crash down to earth while
buildings and bridges would crumble and
collapse under the increased
gravitational pressure only thick trees
that were low to the ground would remain
standing but it's unlikely that much
else could shoulder the added weight you
would be significantly heavier and you
probably wouldn't be able to walk
anywhere
think about it if you weigh 50 kg on
Earth right now it would feel like you
weighed 1,400 Kg on a sun-sized earth
the cruel twist is that as gravity
increases time would slow down so you
might be able to live longer but it
would probably be a long life spent
lying in bed with aches and
pains luckily we can wake up from this
nightmare because the Earth will never
be as big as the sun
in fact our planet is actually getting
smaller our atmosphere leaks and so we
end up losing several hundred tons of
Mass to space every
day so take a nice deep breath and be
glad it's that easy it's not always a
good idea to mess with proportions and
bigger definitely doesn't always mean
[Music]
better Jupiter your Uranus Saturn
Earth sadly the Earth didn't make it
onto the list of the solar systems
ringed planets if it did would it still
be able to host
life this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth had Rings like
Saturn when the Earth was young it most
likely had a ring of rock debris around
it 4 and 1/2 billion years ago another
plan Planet Thea hit the earth the giant
impact sent a ring of matter hurling
into the Earth's orbit but it didn't
stay like that for long the rocky debris
soon formed another Celestial body the
one we now call the
moon having planetary Rings visible in
the sky would look way more spectacular
than just one gray rock right maybe but
if our planet got beautiful Rings like
these tomorrow much of life on Earth
might not survive of the renovation
process it wouldn't necessarily take
another Collision to form rings around
the earth we could just crumble the moon
and for that we'd only need to move it a
little
closer the gravitational pull that our
planet exerts on the moon isn't equal
everywhere it's much stronger on the
side of the moon that is closest to us
there is a limit on how close celestial
bodies can be to each other it's called
the RO limit
if they get any closer than that limmit
the larger body shreds the smaller one
into
pieces the distance of the roach limit
depends on the size mass and density of
the two objects for instance the sun
rips up comets that come within 1.3
million km of it the Earth will tear
apart an average sized Comet from
approximately 18,000 km away for the
moon the RO limit would be about 9500
km the Rings we might get from something
the size of the Moon would be about
5,000 km wide and around 9 1/2 km thick
but unlike Saturn's icy Rings ours would
be made of nothing but Rock the Earth is
just too close to the Sun to keep the
debris
iced looking out at the sky you'd be
able to see these rings from Earth at
all times because of the brightness of
the Rings the moon wouldn't seem as
bright anymore that is if we still had
the moon if the moon crumbled up and
became our Rings well there'd be nothing
else up there to look at and there would
be some other
consequences the Rings suddenly hugging
Earth would disrupt internal navigation
systems of some animals if not enough
direct sunlight was making it through
the Rings they would also affect
photosynthesis and our oxygen supply in
the shadow of the Rings with no contact
from the sun's Rays the temperature
would get so cold that it would make the
shadowed areas of the earth almost
uninhabitable
communication satellites generally
placed around the earth's equator would
find themselves right in the middle of a
rock storm we'd need to find another way
to keep the internet alive if we want to
keep posting selfies on a ringed Earth
we'd be better off in a scenario where
the Earth has always been like this
provided we didn't lose sunlight and
oxygen we'd evolve just fine but we'd
have to develop other means of
communication since we wouldn't be able
to send satellites into an orbit full of
rocks space would never become our final
frontier the rocky rings around the
planet would be a sort of orbital barbed
wire fence keeping us all
grounded and just like the rings of
Saturn Earth's Rings wouldn't last
forever one day they'd start to feel
their age and drop from the sky make
sure to wear a helmet and don't forget
to look up and enjoy the
show if the Multiverse is real there
might be a ring Earth somewhere out
there with people on it wondering what
it would be like to live on a planet
with no
[Music]
rings the biggest planet in the solar
system has gone
Rogue and now it's heading straight
toward Earth you have 30 days till this
gas giant wipes us all
out what speeds would Jupiter be
traveling at
what kind of Havoc would it wreak along
the
way and is there any way we could
survive getting eaten by a planetary
Pacman this is what if and here's what
would happen if Jupiter collided with
Earth in our night sky Jupiter appears a
lot like a bright star from our Earthly
point of view only Venus and the moon
are
brighter but something strange is going
on 588 million kilm away Jupiter has
ramped up its speed to
225 km per second that's 15 times faster
than its usual orbital
velocity so now this gas giant 11 times
larger and 3177 times times heavier than
Earth is on the loose and it's going to
speed right at us until it's filled up
the entire night
sky but don't worry you could already be
dead long before those 30 days are
up as it moved toward Earth Jupiter
would first pass through the asteroid
belt this region between Jupiter and
Mars consists of hundreds of thousands
of Rocky bodies ranging from Tiny dust
particles to asteroids almost 1,000 km
in width but none of these would do
anything to slow down the gas giant the
average distance between these asteroids
is about equal to seven Jupiters in a
row so there's a chance the planet could
pass through completely
unscathed and in our night sky Jupiter
would now look double its usual size
which doesn't seem like a whole lot to
make everyone panic but that doesn't
mean it wouldn't cause a little bit of
chaos on its trip you see Jupiter is
vital to our solar system and to life on
Earth it acts as a gatekeeper to our
cozy planetary neighborhood protecting
us from being bombarded with giant
life-ending asteroids all the time
why well because Jupiter's gravitational
pull is massive about four times
stronger than Earth's this strong pull
redirects asteroids that could be on a
collision course with us and this is
good news for you because even one
asteroid as small as 5 km across could
end life on Earth as you know it just
like what happened to the dinosaurs
around 6 66 million years
ago but if Jupiter suddenly started
heading toward the center of the solar
system it could send many dangerous
space rocks our way if one of them
smashed into Earth you might not live
long enough to see Jupiter swallow Earth
but for the sake of our hypothetical
scenario let's keep you alive for
now while sending asteroids on a
collision course with Earth
Jupiter could also pick up a new moon or
two the asteroid belt is home to the
only dwarf planet in the inner solar
system series it has about 25% of the
total mass of the entire belt maybe this
dwarf planet would join the 79 other
moons that make up Jupiter's very faint
ring
system next stop would be Mars and and
now Jupiter would appear almost four
times larger than usual from Earth now
while the red planet could be lucky
enough to avoid being obliterated by a
head-on impact with Jupiter it might not
make it out
untouched maybe the newly added Moon
series would slam into it and this
wouldn't be Mars's first rodeo either
about 700 million years after the
formation of our solar
system a huge asteroid even larger than
siries collided with Mars that Collision
tore Away part of the Martian Hemisphere
and the debris from that asteroid
started orbiting the red planet
eventually forming its Two Moons Phobos
and
deos these moons still orbit Mars
today now at 16 million km away Jupiter
would would be closing in on the home
stretch from Earth you'd see it bright
and clear as large as the moon and from
this point on you'd start to feel some
of the effects of Jupiter's powerful
magnetic field this field is the largest
object in the solar system and it's
18,000 times more powerful than
Earth's it would be so strong that it
could trap charged particles and
accelerate them these particles would
damage electronics in our passing
spacecraft and they could potentially
penetrate Earth's atmosphere and
magnetic field and that would be really
bad
news now you were lucky to avoid one of
these planetk killing asteroid
collisions but now you and everyone else
on planet Earth would start to suffer
from severe radiation
sickness first you'd be incapacitated by
nausea diarrhea and vomiting you'd also
feel anxiety confusion and could lose
Consciousness after a few torturous
hours you'd start to feel okay but then
the final stage would kick in you'd
experience Tremors and convulsions
before ending up in a coma or
worse if somehow you survived this the
ultimate end would draw nearer and
nearer now only 2 million kilm away the
Great Red Spot would be the same size as
the moon and the planet itself would
appear eight times larger than that rock
above us Earth would now be caught in a
violent game of tug-of war between
Jupiter and the sun this could could
cause tidal heating all around our
planet Earth could become a hell hole
riddled with earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions that would spew sulfur dioxide
gases into space all the while Jupiter
would be making its Final
Approach now as close as the Moon it
would occupy 40 times more space in our
night sky and as it crashes into Earth
the atmosphere of both planets would
compress this would rapidly increase the
temperature causing everything on Earth
including the air itself to burst into
flames and in this colossal Inferno
Earth would burn up in Jupiter's
atmosphere until we fuse with the gas
giant
forever I guess you could call us pretty
unlucky to be the only planet swallowed
up by Jupiter I wonder what would happen
if Jupiter swallowed up all the others
too well that's a story for
another what
if there are hundreds of billions of
alien worlds in the Milky Way
galaxy and scientists have already
discovered and confirmed over 5